deux ans jour pour jour après l'arrivée
d'emmanuel macro aux responsabilités
l'espoir et le renouveau ont laissé la
place à la déception à la colère au
ras-le-bol
un anniversaire loin d'être joyeux pour
les français si toutes les fractures de
notre pays ne sont pas apparus avec vous
vos décisions et votre arrogance
collective ont contribué à toutes les
aggraver trois français sur quatre
prochaines déjà votre politique hausse
de la csg des taxes sur le carburant 80
km heure ce sont vos décisions
deux tiers des retraités ont subi de
lourdes pertes de pouvoir d'achat les
entreprises redoutent maintenant les
milliards d'euros d'impôts
supplémentaires annoncés et les
agriculteurs n'ont pas vu leurs revenus
progresser ou leurs contraintes baisser
les français ne sont pas dupes monsieur
le premier ministre
vos mesures d'urgence ne leur rende
qu'une petite partie de ce que vous leur
avez pris en 2018 et les chiffres
concrets rendent bien mieux compte de la
médiocrité de votre bilan que vos
discours grandiloquents avec vous la
france n'est pas seulement devenue
championne du monde de football mais
surtout championne du monde des taxes et
impôts qui étouffe entreprises et
ménages pour la première fois de son
histoire la france sera cette année le
pire déficit de la zone euro avec un
montant de dépenses publiques jamais vue
en matière d'immigration votre obsession
à vouloir répartir les migrants plutôt
qu'à empêcher l'arrivée de ce que nous
ne pouvons plus accueillir débouche sur
un record de titres de séjour et une
hausse de 11% de l'immigration ces
résultats déplorables et vos dépenses
supplémentaires sans économies sur la
garantie d'un nouveau matraquage fiscal
demain pour nos entreprises et les
salariés
la sphère benalla et les gilet jaune
enfin ont montré votre cynisme vody
stimulation et votre manque de lucidité
et d' écoute
alors monsieur le premier ministre après
deux ans où l'on a entendu tout et son
contraire
comptez vous continuer à faire de votre
mandat le jumeau pitoyable de celui de
françois hollande ou au final ce sont
toujours les travailleurs et les classes
moyennes qui paye la note de votre
absence de courage et de vos mensonges
au cours des longues semaines qu'on va
durer ce grand débat la question de la
mobilité au quotidien dans les
territoires a été soulevée par de
nombreuses interviews
en premier rang desquels les maires des
communes rurales la question du prix des
carburants
celle de la limitation de vitesse à 80
km heure ne sont pas étrangères à la
colère qui s'est exprimée dans les
territoires elle demeure un sujet de
préoccupation pour des cons vos
concitoyens assurément plus que
l'hypothétique lifting de l'ena dont ils
n'ont pas identifié la priorité depuis
le début de l'année les prix des
carburants sont repartis à la hausse est
en passe d'atteindre aujourd'hui des
niveaux record ce qui suscite
l'inquiétude légitime de ceux qui n'ont
pas d'alternative à l'utilisation
quotidienne de leur véhicule et ne
peuvent pas se contenter de réponses au
long terme si le gouvernement n'a pas la
maîtrise des cours du pétrole
il a par contre le pouvoir de moduler
les taxes ou de les plafonner pour ne
pas rajouter à la flambée des prix autre
sujet qui impactent fortement la
mobilité dans les territoires la
limitation de vitesse imposée sans
concertation contestée par de nombreux
élus locaux qui ont vu leur territoire
renouer avec des temps de trajet des
années 80 je vous ai bien écouter à
l'époque et je vous cite pour la
première fois depuis 18 ans la sécurité
sociale retrouvera l'équilibré
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour les jeunes
générations la bonne nouvelle n'était
semble-t-il qu'une fête news puisque
finalement nassif hitti social pour être
affiché à fin de l'année un déficit de 3
milliards 6 ce qu'annonce le haut
conseil de financement de la sécurité
sociale dans son rapport du mois de mars
ce rapport précise même qu aucun
équilibre n'est envisageable avant la
fin du quinquennat
des promesses d'un petit excédent de 600
millions d'euros se sont envolés le
discours de fin d'année a été happé par
l'arrêt
comment madame la ministre pouvez vous
expliquer et justifier un tel décalage
entre les prévisions présentées comme la
preuve incontestable de la bonne gestion
du gouvernement et la réalité des
chiffres qui seront ceux de la fin de
l'année 2019 le 1er mai plusieurs
dizaines de manifestants certains par
effraction ont pénétré dans l'enceinte
de l'hôpital de la pitié salpêtrière
pour échapper aux gaz lacrymogènes
cette irruption dans un lieu de soins
étaient de nature à susciter une
légitime émotion
heureusement aucune agression ne semble
avoir été commise et les manifestants
n'ont apparemment pas pénétrer dans les
bâtiments
je veux d'ailleurs ici salué le sang
froid le calme et le formidable
professionnalisme des personnels de
santé pour maintenir les patients à
l'abri de cette agitation qui a fait
peur hélas on ne peut pas dire que le
gouvernement et fait preuve du même sang
froid
[Musique]